welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens filling in for Eric Voss
while he's out on paternity leave and
this is a breakdown of the trailer for
Grand Theft Auto 6 the highly
anticipated followup to the wildly
successful GTA 5 released all the way
back in September of 2013 the trailer
revealed that GTA 6 will be coming at
some point in 2025 meaning that it will
be over 11 years since we've had a new
Grand Theft Auto game 11 years
that's a little bit older than my nephew
this game looks massive it looks amazing
and I'm sure this is a trailer more of
cinematics of the game more than it is
actual gameplay but there's still a ton
of hidden gems here to talk about so
let's dive into the trailer a truck with
Patriot beer a brand of beer in GTA
since it's come online Drives By as we
Feast our eyes upon the beautiful
sunrise over a coastal Skyline I think
you can see Vice City skyline in the
distance like many had guessed after the
teaser image was released before the
trailer GTA 6 will be taking players
back to Vice City the Miami of the GTA
universe so Vice City represents Miami
and leonida represents Florida folks
online have already speculated this
comes from the Explorer Juan Ponch de
Leon probably pronounced that wrong I'm
so sorry a Spanish explorer who led an
expedition to Florida in 1513 GTA 3 and
four took us to the Liberty City AKA New
York City GTA 5 and GTA San Andreas took
us to Los Santos AKA Los Angeles and of
course GTA Vice City originally
introduced the south Florida location
the game originally released in 2002 was
set in the 80s but this time Vice City
appears to be in present day and boy do
I love it the graphics look stunning The
Amazing company that did Red Dead
Redemption those Graphics were also
amazing and they came out like 5 years
ago so I'm assuming now like most
Rockstar Games it'll come out on the
current hardware and a PC version later
people are expecting like 35 frames a
second on a console I'm betting they'll
aim higher and do 60 because like just
be ambitious it's been 11 years we're
introduced to one of the game's
protagonists Lucia the first time the
standard GTA game not a DLC has featured
a woman as the main playable character
in The Last GTA you were able to play as
a couple of playable characters Michael
Trevor Franklin this time it looks like
we'll have only two Lucia and Jason with
the noted Bonnie and Clyde Vibe kind of
going on I'm sure they have both unique
skills that the other characters in the
last games had so I'm expecting a lot
from these two the first time we see
Lucia is behind bars in a prison
jumpsuit I like how looking through this
window feels like looking at a van go
painting we even see the dirtt particles
floating in the sunlight you can see a
photo of her family or someone's family
at her bunk bed it's hard to make it out
then she's talking to either her parole
officer or possibly a social worker
named Stephanie like many GTA main
characters luciao is probably someone
who has been on the wrong side of the
law in the past and will continue to be
in the future as of right now Rockstar
Games has not confirmed the voice actors
for this game but the internet is trying
its best to figure it out she blames her
predicament on bad luck but I'm sure
it's a little more than that then we get
our first proper look at Vice City
beaches which
look I am eating this up it looks
amazing there's a plane flying by with a
banner reading why 69 when you get 919
advertising a club called 919 and yeah
if you didn't know these games could be
quite gross and I love it in Miami
there's a club called 11 spelled with
with the numbers in it so clearly a
spoof of that if you don't have those
cinematic drone shots on the beach are
you really at a beach you know what I'm
saying I love how games have focused on
the cinematics using common film shots
like needing an overhead drone shot to
give off the spring break Beach Vibes
and movies we just know what we're
already getting ourselves into as Tom
Petty's love is a long road really kicks
in retreated to some stunning Vistas and
locations Tom Petty was born and raised
in Gainesville Florida so it's great
they got a Florida Boy song for the
trailer we see an airboat streaking
across a swamp classic South Florida
activity and I'm going to ride the hell
out of that airboat some flamingos
Taking Flight with some Gators hiding in
the bushes there aren't any wild
flamingos anymore in Florida sadly but
maybe GTA is a better Universe than ours
also we're going to see a lot of gators
in this trailer so many Gators maybe the
same Gator who knows keep an eye on
every motor vehicle a lot of them are
returning but it also signifies how much
bigger this game will be there's a ton
of flying vehicles in this trailer
hopefully there's some form of fast
travel but if I get to fly a helicopter
or drive an airboat I really won't even
care about the Fast Travel it's like in
Spider-Man I'm just going to flip around
and fly on my gliders this is the scene
that's literally straight out of a movie
we're at Vice Beach and it's popping we
have jet skis returning and in the
distance you can see a lifeguard station
in helicopters Soul Sisters make the
umbrellas the characters look incredible
the variety of swimwear and big booties
like this is really in an impeccable
game and I hope my system whatever I'm
playing it on can run it also what the
hell is this man up to over there what
is he doing this is so weird attention
to detail a boats race in the water past
the cargo ship called the BTN delmare
I'm sure there will be Shenanigans in
this game taking place on that cargo
ship the boat in the front says claron
then we see a woman in a green dress
rising from the passenger seat of a pagi
zero this might be our Lucia I'm not too
sure a man is taking a photo from his
grat Faria both cars making a return I
going to get into all these cars in GTA
or at least most of them and I will be
pronouncing majority of them wrong and
I'm so sorry we're taking the exit to
Catalin Boulevard Stockyard downtown but
the other exit is to Kelly County and
Vice City International Airport
locations we might be able to visit in
the game this next shot we see more cars
lots of low riders and modified cars
this is the green Chrysler 300 in the
game that car has been upgraded from the
Shyer PMP 600 we saw in GTA 5 the Albany
Buccaneer we've seen from GTA 5 the
Tulip M100 we got online this is also
Jason and Lucia's car we see later I
think the Rolls-Royce cullinen AKA The
enus Jubilee and some basic CS we've
seen before in the past games we're
taken to a strip club with bottle
service hello this could be Club 919
that we saw advertised earlier again the
graphics are stupendous you can see
every little jiggle I tried to look
closer at the money and found a better
shot later in the trailer the bills
Lucia is holding says United States of
paranoia I assume all the bills say this
it also has a date for 0410 1998 which
is on the same bills in the GTA contract
DLC people have alluded it might be the
company's start date Rockstar Games you
let me know what you think because when
I looked it up it didn't say April 10th
1998 it just said 1998 I also noticed
the man's shirt says dolls of
destraction nothing of importance in GTA
so this is new and the banner says Make
It Rain Mondays in GTA 5 we had the
strip club Vanilla Unicorn like pole
positions maybe you can eventually own
this club too and I will try my hardest
we see a bunch of fine cars in Vice City
returning from previous Gams mainly five
the blue one is the Fister Comet S2
Cabrio then there's the classic grate
cheetah the cheetah has been a popular
car since like GTA 3 the red one is the
grat carbon AER or carbon aera the
pretty car from GTA 5 the orange and
black one is the bravado Gauntlet
Hellfire from online they even have a
Lamborghini Aventador these cars are
spectacular and I'm going to try
stealing all of them all of this is to
say that if you love cars you're going
to love this game if you love this game
you probably love cars also the man on
the ground has an iguana on his shoulder
between the alligator small NPC players
with their dogs and iguanas this game is
pretty sick and cool also I learned that
in Florida you can actually kill the
iguanas because they're invasive and
people eat them that is insane to me
Florida is a different world to me one
shot energy I I'll try one I'll try one
and if it doesn't wake me up I'm going
to be
pissed oh
[Music]
yeah
I know Kung
[Music]
Fu okay I want to try the focus ones
now
eternity
okay one shot is really all I need I
think they both clashed in me and now I
don't know where I'm at begin your
transformation with oneshot energy today
by going to oneshot energy.com neww
rockstars for 10% off your order I am
going crazy I am an insane person I have
to go see a musical I have to go sit in
a theater oh my God we get a beautiful
view of Florida or I guess Leonid keys
with a completely broken Highway which
will probably be interfering within the
game cuts to woman in this FL Louis
Vuitton style bikini at a rooftop party
now I know I'm going to pronounce this
wrong this is the infamous GTA fashion
brand I always read it I never have said
it Sante no then we start getting into
these hilarious those super entertaining
social media posts when I thought it
couldn't get worse screen time on
Twitter tweeted a lot of these posts
come from actual Florida viral moments
online the woman with the hammer I
remember but I don't remember the others
which Florida come on we are just a mess
I I'm not even from Florida it just
makes us look like a mess we see a yacht
with American flags and young women with
an older man and of course this is like
Miami the post is from Dad bod Squad it
says I puppy save some sugar bab for the
rest of us if you know you know if you
listen to city girls you know Miami is
popping for Sugar Babies a man wrestling
to get an alligator out of a normal pool
with a normal device to catch like stray
raccoons the post is from official poach
it says stay alert VC remember to check
for uninvited guests before the pool
party and I'm praying this is a pivotal
moment in the game where we need to
remove an alligator my girl have a vice
day someone called the Department of
Transport on this dump truck # have a
vice day a great hashtag but also the
heavy social media component from the
NPCs are harboring only chaos and this
is a great attention to detail from
Rockstar Games in my personal opinion I
think Rockstar Games really brought NPCs
to life making our surroundings feel
less of a virtual world and more reality
so I'm not surprised we have scenes like
this but I'm in awe of how far they've
come to add this new hot social media
element like this specific one a live
stream at the intersection at this burn
out this woman on top of the pink car
big booties and metallic clothing what's
more Florida than this zazza nuggets
saying the best song right now long time
coming we really out here hey yo catch a
Vibe going to spin the block with this
one and this is the poop Emoji bomb
emoji again the PCS are at work but
can't help but think whether this is a
cinematic scene that leads straight into
gameplay or we're going to get some hot
licensed music what music will they use
in 2025 GTA 6 we all love the radio
stations we got DJ khed a little bit in
GTA 5 and I mean truly the world will be
our oyster in 2025 watch it be like sexy
red we're then taken to a convenience
store where an alligator is just walking
through the front door of a security cam
footage outside the window it says go
postal which is the Postal Service in
GTA from GTA 5 no one is phased by the
alligator regardless proving that this
is the norm for these folks like this
man literally watering his grass in a
g-ring this is the norm for them even
getting some scary body cam footage from
police staying as close and grounded to
reality top right the body cam reads 84
for August 4th and the cam has been
going for almost 24 hours outside Arrow
gas station a common gas station in GTA
mainly online you'll see it's branding a
man in a g- string runs chased by a cop
the post is from it Leonid man usually
got to hit the strip club to see a
jiggle like that for real these captions
who wrote them we need to find them and
hire them General custard Cannon post
only Leonid is a crotch grab and apology
for bad driving also yes I get it's
probably a cinematic transition in the
game I get it this is probably not
Gameplay at all but let's talk about
these visuals we keep calling it The Red
Dead look and yes it's gorgeous but it's
also giving Spider-Man two details the
tattoos of the alligator on this man the
shirt ripped down the chest saying we
bite back in leonita I wanted sign in
the top left for panty sniffing the
construction and post- Rain drizzle with
the sun peeking behind the clouds it's
just gorgeous I love this God whatever
station I have will not be able to play
this game it will crash I cannot afford
it yo mama's Jammer said rip Rudy see
you in heaven cuz I'm zooming this is
Rudy and he's dead his truck is a part
of Vice vinyl though and we should keep
a lookout for those details even the
hash write out customs these little
spots of commercial advertisement in the
game are what makes the game so grounded
and fun and their design team definitely
work hard to put that stuff in there so
look at it I didn't even think about it
but what's Florida without mudding you
know we see some folks drunk having the
time of their lives in thrillbilly Mud
Club American flag bikinis stuck ATVs in
the mud and not a single care in the
world I think in the back we see a
version of the GTA 5's Liberator and I'm
sure they're showcasing this in the
trailer as a place you can go maybe when
you're bored or exploring what the new
map has to offer I'm sure this next spot
is the same spot this man elbow dropping
on the beer table full of patriot beer
Lucha Libre fan is live posting
neighborhood watch don't play around in
Hamlet Hamlet seems to be one of the
minor cities within the game the Char
says well look who's back and clearly it
ain't our first time there's a real in
veres Florida in veres being a location
in Scotland referenc to MC Beth could be
a reference to that Lucia and Jason
drive past some cops we see a billboard
for angst toan it cures emotions
America's favorite dish associative
weasel news is later seen in the trailer
we've seen them in the past games
they're the Patriotic news site hence
the logo a play on Fox News they're
showing footage of cops arresting
someone who's flipped their car trying
to escape from a Dy and dash and I think
we see him arrested right here this is
another Florida online sensation the
Joker Miami this game is really just
coming for Florida it reads confessions
written in tattoo Inc the tattoo on his
neck gave him away led the conviction of
a man of Leonid on his neck we all only
see like guns but maybe this tattoo
means something to keep an eye out for
he also has a tattoo on his chin that
just says Party Time behind him in the
badge for the correctional facility of
Vice City and this is the image of a son
a snake hanging from a palm tree and an
alligator coming out of the water and I
think attacking someone if that ain't
Florida I don't know what is it also is
not too far off from the actual Florida
police badge when Lucia says we need to
stick together we see family of bikers
people on ATV riding down the
neighborhood having fun then the weasel
news calls them dirt bike dirt bags God
it says cops fail to stop thugs on
motorbikes terrorizing Vice City then
underneath that on the ticker it says
mental patient wins Vice City Marathon
leonida Man sucked up in water spout
demands the city buy him a new suit then
it cuts off at Vice City girls
officially and I'm wondering if they got
the city girls music on this game and
this is a call out to them because how
perfect would that be
I genuinely like the city girls clearly
I've mentioned them twice now another
social media posting of high rollers mag
posting a video on high rollers
lifestyle it looks like there's going to
be some street racing behind the man
looks like the same Chrysler 300 we saw
at the car shop so this man could have
just got an upgrade when Lucia and Jason
are in this store we see a bunch of
Easter eggs we have piss water the
German logger advertised on the radio
and TV and GTA let's grab a case with
piss drink for the
USA logger beer a common beer also
advertised in GTA and also ecola we see
the car peel out in front of the pond
and gun and gun and pawn shop this is
probably where you get your weapons
Jason and Luci are driving the tulip car
they have a ton of bumper stickers but I
can't take my eyes off the one that says
save the bees they probably stole this
car there's so much to spot when they
walk into the liquor store guns blazing
the store is called Uncle Jack there's
the new logger light Petty forever which
at first I thought was like to be mean
forever but it's probably for Tom Petty
whose song has been playing throughout
this entire trailer the Ombre color on
the sticker is also very Tom Petty the
sign says will you will no longer accept
cash St and underwear and rightfully so
pendo cesa definitely a play on pendo
meaning [__] but sounds like an
amazing beer then we close to our new
GTA 6 logo and that is it for my
breakdown on GTA 6 I'm clearly pumped
for it we can expect the game to release
in 2025 probably the latest of 2025
December 2025 I I don't know on PS5 and
Xbox series XS no word on the PC version
yet but we have a long time to wait it
out regardless follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
rockstars subcribe to new Rockstar for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching go buy some
[Music]
games